hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about Delta and
its importance in identifying a
potential low you know an area where the
market can bounce off of now
um before I jump in if you've been
enjoying these videos and learning from
them be sure to subscribe to the channel
click the notification Bell so you don't
miss any new upload and if you find
today's video helpful hit the like
button for me and leave a comment
sharing your biggest takeaway
and more importantly you know if you
have an idea for a video be sure to put
it in the comments and I can put it on
the list of videos to make now I
apologize you know yesterday Wednesday
uh super busy for me I wasn't able to
get a video out so I'll try and play
catch up and get a couple out today so
uh let's go ahead and talk about today's
topic all right so Delta right and you
know I always get a laugh when when I
see comments from people I think
sometimes I think some of you guys are
doing it just to get a rise out of me uh
oh Delta doesn't matter is is this
comment that I get every once in a while
and to be honest you know I joke about
it being
um you know something that triggers me
it really doesn't uh you know it's the
thing that that makes the market so
interesting is that everyone has a
different way of analyzing the market
and there's no one right way of trading
right there's a right way for you to
trade and so people that come out say oh
this doesn't matter at all I mean who
are they to say you know are they the
authority on everything involved in
trading you know I generally find that
the people that make comments like that
are people that are struggling trading
because they don't understand uh you
know the mechanics of the market and why
it's important right and
you know I know guys they trade with
certain methods that you know I just
shake my head but you know who am I to
say oh that's that's a stupid way to
trade the market they make money right
I've met people that literally use
phases of the Moon
to make money they've given me
predictions on the market six months out
and I'll be damned they came true you
know and you know so who might say oh
your face is a moon oh you're you're a
crackpot no you know hey if it works for
you if that's what you believe in and it
works for you more power to you
congratulations you found a way to
approach the market that makes sense to
you okay and for me it's order flow and
Delta you know is a part of order flow
that in my opinion is very important so
um today is uh what day is today is the
7th of September and you know s PS are
continuing their sell-off from yesterday
and when we got into you know we opened
up
touch to low just after the cash bounced
up and then we sort of came back around
you know the 904 to 907 area now I'm
looking at a one minute chart I've
explained this it doesn't matter what
chart type you're looking at the
analysis would be the same if you're
looking at a range based chart analysis
would be the same obviously the way the
candles are going to be formatted
because it's a rain based chart is going
to be slightly different but the
analysis is still the same but I'm just
going to focus on the Deltas okay so
we're coming down back into our low of
the day here all right and at around
904. okay then we just you know we get
within the low is 34 and three quarters
we get as low as five and a quarter so
we're about two ticks off the low now
there's a couple things that uh you know
get my interest one obviously you know
we sort of got this little double bottom
forming we got this nice exhaustion
print coming in here one right it's
bullish ratio as well which is nice to
see coming in at a swing low and we get
this little bit of a bounce but more
importantly what as we're coming down
into the low
you know I see the Delta minus 815 here
so kind of a strong one it's colored
magenta so it's near our Min Delta
number
okay the next bar minus 561 okay so
negative negative still kind of strong I
mean you know even though there's a drop
off from 815 to 561. minus 561 is still
kind of strong coming into the low then
you get one bar with positive Delta okay
got exhaustion print green candle okay
okay I I I'm starting to think you know
hey is this going to be the low or not
then you still see a little bit more
selling you see another red candle
coming in here negative 269 Delta then
you get this green candle
with a negative Delta of 67. so look
take just take a look at how this low
this bottom is forming okay minus 815
Delta minus 561. ignore this 388 for now
so sort of put your finger over that if
you will
I'm just focusing on the negative Deltas
minus 8 15 minus 561 minus 269 minus 67.
and we're sort of forming a little bit
of a base right here okay all right
two ticks off the low
the next two bars three ticks off the
low but more importantly
what's the Delta is telling you right
it's still negative so there's still
some selling pressure but the selling
pressure is getting weaker I think of it
like water pressure right you
lose water pressure yeah water is still
coming out but it's coming out weaker
and weaker and it's the same thing with
the selling pressure they're still
selling pressure but it's just weaker
and weaker and once that selling
pressure is
done right once it's sort of the spigot
is turned off
look for That Bouncy you get that quick
bounce right here right and it rallies
from the 38 area all the way back up to
the 45 sort of goes sideways in here
just sort of hang it around the 40 to 43
area and then we come back down into
another new low
okay so you know you got a little
initial bounce here which was nice to
see you know I I wish it would have been
a bigger bounce
and then what happens next is we come
down in here make a new low okay
and as we're making that low sort of the
same thing that we saw over here down
down negative negative negative negative
but weaker weaker weaker
coming down into this new low it's minus
568 minus 6 18. minus 378 minus 27. you
know nice positive Delta 600 okay and
the market puts in a nice strong rally I
mean it was uh would we rally up from
from about the uh
you know the 37 area all the way up into
the 50s pretty quick I mean this was a
nice sharp rise up and I'm going to talk
about that in in a separate video but um
what do you see selling pressure weaker
weaker weaker
no more now you got aggressive buying
coming in nice positive Delta more
positive Delta more positive Delta so
what do you got in a sense you've got
negative Delta then gets weaker weaker
I'm just looking at the Deltas I'm not
looking at bar collars or anything like
that then positive so it went from
negative to positive to more positive to
more positive I mean just
in this in the one two three four five
six bars
it went from
negative decreasing to positive
increasing what do you think the
Market's going to do it's going to Rally
now do you need to wait till after you
get the third bar this is actually a
Delta surge coming in here but no you
don't you could just identify this
weakness in the Delta coming in here now
in this earlier low obviously you had
the
the one bar with positive Delta which
sort of through a monkey wrench into the
works but sometimes you know you have to
take that step where you overlook it
it's beautiful when it comes in just
like this sequentially minus 6 18 minus
378 minus 27 but there's going to be
times where you just get that little bit
of some buying coming in because
remember right we had rallied up come
down
coming and testing this low so maybe
some of these people that were short
from up here maybe they're trying to buy
down here cover right the intraday
Traders and then you get that bounce
back up
so there was some buying
but are you going to completely dismiss
what's happening in the Delta because
you got one bar with positive Delta
I don't think you should some people
will some people won't I mean that like
I said
you decide what you want to look at when
you're trading right and if you're
experienced enough with the order flow
where you understand it
you can sort of overlook this one this
one bar with the Positive Delta
and take sort of the bigger picture of
what's happened over four out of the
five bars put the pieces together now
on the order flows Trader we actually
got a tool on here called Market
weakness which will detect that all
right if you go under the settings uh or
is it here Market weak weakness detector
here
okay now with the market weakness it's
got to have a sequence of three or more
weakening Deltas either positive or
negative
but you can see right down here right
off this low of the of the day here
at uh you know it's coming in on this
bar you could just you see it's giving
you that signal right that's what this
um
purple line is right it's telling you
hey you know what there was weakness
coming in here now it's changed now's
your your opportunity to be looking to
get long
right and you know again a nice move
from 36 all the way up into the 50s
um very dramatic move up okay now it's
not signaling over here because
obviously you got that one
um
bar with that positive Delta
but overall
out of these four out of the five bars
with the negative Delta it's
consistently getting weaker
then you get a little bit of a pop
so again you know does Delta matter I
think it does you know throw stones at
me do whatever you like
um you know it's a to me it's a major
piece of the order flow analysis that
you want to be paying attention to as a
Trader
and you know if you if you don't think
it's worth anything then then don't use
it there's a lot of other information in
the order flow which you know I'll be
talking about in some of the later
videos because today was it was this
just this morning you know it's only 10
30 but there's there's a lot of
interesting things taking place in the
order flow today so anyway guys I'll see
you on the next video bye bye